I'm going to try celebrity impressions I
[Music]
feel like I can do a few celebrity
impersonations I never ever ever want to
be the person who's just like you got to
hear my so-and-so if you act like you
know what you're doing then other people
think you they know what you're doing
I've never seen any of these papers with
the name written down so I'm just going
to pick one out we're gonna go for it
it's Leviosa not Leviosa Wow
that's all I got I am the Governor of
California I guess it's just a lot of
talk I just use that California needs to
change how we elect our government do
you like that cuz it's as though I
didn't know Arnold Schwarzenegger was
ever an actor I like to do something
about it in a newspaper oh that's
horrible
very great well it's not easy being
green it's not very good what do you
mean you've got me doing impressions in
this room there's a couple of water here
who's drinking water they tell you to
drink eight cups a day no one turns
eight cups a day what's the deal with
taxicabs
this is Seinfeld Christopher Walken I'm
the king of the noise I've seen the
north wall we are all brothers of the
Night Watch we Oh where's my son well
well are you there where's my boy I want
to find my boy habour where in the he's
in the light
male the finger ball oh [ __ ] I can't
even do it anymore I need practice
Shampoo is better I go on first and
clean the hair no conditioner is better
I leave the hair silky and smooth
oh yeah finger boy boys [ __ ]
scrambled eggs there I told you make
some [ __ ] scrambled eggs you act like
a [ __ ] goddamn idiot over there did a
bad job cooking it's gonna be huge huge
huge gonna be huge that this wasn't even
close to what he sounds like at all I
[Applause]
[ __ ] Oprah like Mick Jagger I can do
like Russian Elvis no but you got a
goodie budgie goodie thank you thank you
very much I think that on a scale of 1
to 10 I was a very solid 2.5 I just like
made a lot of weird noises I hope people
in the office couldn't hear me through
the walls they probably think
something's wrong and they're gonna call
the police
thank you you ruined my day I feel
terrible
[Music]